you can only imagine the terror of what
was unfolding inside
fire ripping through the wards of a
hospital beijing's most deadly blaze in
decades
hurry up you can hear them shouting some
the lucky and the able-bodied just able
to escape
but many more vulnerable were left
trapped
authorities say this fire was
extinguished in just half an hour
foreign
but for many it was too late 29 mostly
elderly patients perished here
at a press conference authorities hold a
moment of silence to remember the dead
and then gave more detail about exactly
what happened
after initial investigation the fire was
caused by fire Sparks from construction
work as part of an internal renovation
of the inpatient Department it's ignited
on combustible paint
Save The Next Step will be to learn from
the pain and reflect on this case
the morning after the building bore
signs of the struggle 12 people
including the hospital director have
been arrested and a huge investigation
into fire safety city-wide has been
launched there are lots of signs on the
building of just how rapidly the fire
must have spread one person who did
manage to escape told Chinese media they
didn't hear any fire alarms or see any
sprinklers activated there are questions
now about how so many people lost their
lives and about safety standards too
and the authorities clearly know this
there was an intense police presence
here by the rules we are allowed to film
in the streets we were repeatedly
stopped and moved on
they know it doesn't look good
public anger is so often suppressed here
but it does exist such a mass loss of
life may well spark it there could well
be a reckoning to come Helen Ann Smith
Sky News in Beijing